joining us now senator Ted Cruz so the
great state of Texas senator how are you
good to see you Sean great to be with
you i watch it i watch closely and i I'm
paying very close attention it's now
every second minute hour of everyday
hating Donald Trump and then it's the
new Green Deal and it's socialism at a
level we've never seen before and with a
predictable result correct
look the debate last night take a sip of
water by the way that's your Marco Rubio
moment just in case you don't know it
happens the whole worried about it
senator it's okay but the thing is when
you look at the Democrats you pay close
attention they seem to have a few agenda
items hating Trump new Green Deal yep
look the debate last night the the clown
car is broken there's no break and it
only steers left I guess a it was scary
last night it was scary to see the
Democrats every one of them falling all
over each each other to get further and
further and further left you saw the
Democrats you just went through it your
monologue power powerfully you saw them
embrace late term abortions you saw them
embrace 70 percent tax rates you saw
them embrace socialism you saw them tell
the American people they want to take
away everyone's health insurance and you
saw them embrace open borders one of the
most disturbing exchanges is when is
when several of those candidates began
saying they wanted to eliminate the
provision and law that makes it illegal
to cross the border that makes it a
crime to cross the border illegally now
Sean as you know last month we
apprehended over a hundred and
forty-four thousand people in the month
of May crossing illegally well the
Democrats solution of that is well let's
not make it a crime there we go the
problem goes away that is open borders
it's irresponsible and and it is sadly
where the Democratic Party is today you
know I I know how did we go from
supporting Obama's position to it's
immoral and you know the guy that you
knew Robert you know Francis bozo bado
whatever his name is you know literally
is saying tear down the walls but yet
90% of America's
comes across that border will losing 300
people a week in the opioid crisis then
fentanyl add that to the mix I've
interviewed these border agents that
have spent you know over a decade
talking about children young girls being
trafficking trafficked for prostitution
yes whoa 11 12 13 years old and on you
and I have both been down to the border
together I'm gonna be going on Monday
back to the border to really try to
highlight the crisis we're having there
now we saw some positive development
today and that Congress finally passed
what the president asked for four and a
half billion dollars that includes over
a billion dollars for border patrol that
includes over 200 million dollars for
ice that's good but here's the bad news
the Democrats in Congress refused to
close the loopholes the loopholes that
are causing this crisis that they refuse
to do anything to fix the crisis and
what that means I'll tell you one of the
most disturbing reports I'm getting Sean
I'm getting more and more reports from
law enforcement of cartels and
traffickers renting children because the
idiotic policy that the Democrats have
put in place is if that someone shows up
with a child that they are allowed to
stay they're allowed to go free and as a
result you're seeing little children who
are suddenly they're finding more and
more instances where they're with adults
that are not their parents that are not
their family that are strangers to them
but but the child is essentially their
get-out-of-jail-free card that is cruel
to incentivize kids being abused like
that and you know what the Democrats on
that stage the Democrats on the stage
right now not a single one of them is
willing to do anything to fix it okay so
open borders and amnesty is the big part
of their agenda I don't even think the
issue is about abortion when you say no
restrictions on abortion then we get
into then we get into what happened in
Virginia and all these other states
where they talk about during birth it's
not abortion it's infanticide or post
birth infanticide then we've got a 70
percent top marginal tax rate for
individuals 90 percent for for
corporations how many people's Texas
take
a year now in terms of gating population
this one wasn't close to 400,000 in the
last year we get over a thousand people
a day a diamond to the state of Texas
why cuz that's where the jobs are just
there free was like New York yeah all
right no wait a minute so Mike Huckabee
says on the show the other day now if
you're taking a u-haul from California
to Texas it's about 1600 bucks I had not
heard that but if you returning it
you're basically doing u-haul a favor
it's 400 bucks but it's probably
negotiable they might give it to you for
a hundred Mike is exactly right and for
a long time the price differential going
to California versus going to Texas it's
been about a 300% price differential at
u-haul that's been true for years
because everyone is fleeing the sinking
ship as you have the crazy left jacking
up taxes jacking up regulations that
they're just and and welcoming people
coming illegally and and and the job
producers the small business owners are
fleeing the state of California and and
in Texas I'll tell you something
interesting Shawn as the story came out
a couple of months ago you know with the
number one city in the United States of
America for Millennials moving into it
is my hometown of Houston Millennials
are moving to Houston the most diverse
big city in America why you come to
Texas their jobs their jobs and the
wages are going up and you have
opportunity because the government
doesn't put their boot on the back of
the necks of small businesses all right
so here we have it was interesting is
Bill Maher I don't like him but he is
sometimes he makes some very honest
statements and he said yeah not a good
start because they didn't answer the
first question you know 70% of America
we had now have the best employment
situation in America since 1969
principles by the way that you have
supported your entire career cutting
taxes deregulation we're now energy
independent for the first time in 75
years
the new Green Deal says no oil no gas in
ten years and by the way many of them
are buying into this insanity you know
that that the new Green Deal now what
would that do to a state like Texas what
would that do to the economy in general
if you had a 70%
personal tax rate 90 percent corporate
tax what would it do what we in
destroyed jobs it would destroy
opportunity all across this country you
know that tweet you mentioned from Bill
Maher I did something I don't think I've
done before i retweeted today bill maher
because his tweet was exactly right he
said look the first question in the
debate was a very good first 70% of
Americans were retweeting Bill Maher I
like that but but he but he rightly
pointed out you just you just said it he
said look 70 percent of Americans say
the economy is doing well why do you
guys think we should change it and not a
one of the Democrats had an answer we've
got you know this shot and your viewers
know this we got the lowest unemployment
in 50 years where the lowest
african-american unemployment ever
recorded the lowest Hispanic
unemployment ever recorded and what
they're proposing the green New Deal
would cost 93 trillion dollars now it's
hard sometimes to understand million
what a trillion or a million or million
let me put that in perspective
ninety-three trillion dollars is more
money than the federal government has
spent in the entire history of the
United States of America going back to
George Washington it would mean about
sixty five thousand dollars per family
in America per year that's where the
Democrats are they're just look Donald
Trump has broken the Democratic Party
they hate him so much
that they're embracing policies that
would destroy jobs across America and
open up our borders it's wrong Hey we
went from Obama Biden eight years
thirteen million new Americans on food
stamps eight million poverty now we have
six million off of food stamps and 6
million new jobs and the best employment
situation since 1969 senator good to see
you thank you for being with us